foreign
[Music]
for some time also opening this Breaking
Bad prequel was a Breaking Bad sequel
who's really smart so I'm sure they will
touch on it all throughout the season
instead of just making us wait an entire
year to see more of it if they wanted
that button to be fully accurate it
would say Cinnabon I'm making the world
a more diabetic Place damn it I couldn't
even get two minutes into this thing
without bowing to the aesthetic genius
that is Vince Gilligan song the black
and white the angles the patience nobody
lives in his environments like Vince
when I'm taking off a sin for anyone
that can make a freaking Mall look this
beautiful man Even though this guy isn't
staring at Saul and is approaching the
people outside the store who's at the
very least a serial killer right wow
great escalator camera work guys it
really makes me feel like I made a bad
purchase in this mall which is a flat
flexible shell that allows you to hide
in rock crevassid that announcer
confused crevasses with crevices and
that's not okay keep your ass space
crevasses to yourself show when legal
forces have you cornered Better Call
Saul roll and most importantly
Better Call Saul
it's never too late
[Music]
commercials already hair dryers Saul is
practicing his statements to a jury of
his peers here all I can think about is
how this urinal Puck ended up outside
its intended home did someone reach down
and pulling out the guy who changes them
just miss and somehow not noticed
someone streams so powerful that tsunami
that back onto their feet what's the
deal with this journal tampering
oh to be 19 again I know jurisputin's
expert but can he just walk back in here
and immediately start lawyering doesn't
he have to be recognized by the judge or
something Order in the Court I want to
order okay wait for it death doesn't
discriminate between the Sinners and the
Saints it takes and it takes and it
takes and sorry sometimes I block out
and start singing Hamilton numbers when
I see kids decapitating and defiling
corpses this check has no routing or
account information I mean for obvious
reasons but still real checks have that
did nobody tell you to try all three of
them together one trial seven hundred
dollars but clearly the payment amount
could have been explained to him up
front takes a job like this without
knowing the payment specifics especially
someone is money hungry assault only for
15 minutes in and the show is Airman
trouting and while I love him too I'm
just hoping this doesn't turn into
better call cameos the only way that
entire car is worth 500 bucks is if
there's a 300 hooker sitting in it 300
hookers generally bring the price of the
vehicle down in my experience and very
rarely does the car purchase include the
hooker in my experience
appropriation checking the mail and
seeing a bunch of bills with past dues
stamped on the envelope as an indication
of how bad things are cliched for trash
shadowing and yeah
well a town sned Beatty from Network
Christ sakes guys Chris at CinemaSins
staff meetings every single time also
explaining your references wow Betsy and
Craig just happened to show up at the
exact moment that Jimmy was here anyway
I'm glad this will be the last
coincidence in this show or this episode
ground yourself yes I grounded myself
parroting Circa 2020. your argument is
built on quicksand therefore it
collapses but if it was built on
quicksand would it sink sure doesn't
know how to Metaphor correctly you're
representing people who have nowhere
else to turn you're telling me those
preppy kids didn't have parents with
enough money to actually hire a lawyer
but parents are going to let their kids
risk jail time with a public defendant
Hamlet's making you a jump I'm going to
get better
I'm gonna go back to work and I'm
picking up where I left off Vincent the
gang are putting out Oscar caliber short
films every week on this show and my
hands are tied how do you not keep
taking off sins for this kind of work
let me tell you
about a young guy Story Time with Jimmy
McGill scene is textbook stuff from The
Marvelous cinematic gillibence but my
question is why are these two putting up
with this long-winded moralizing sure
they were promised money but at the very
least they'd be asking him to get to the
point already and maybe go somewhere and
talk where you know chance getting
murdered by a dumb kid who can't control
his bicycle the setting makes all the
Cinematic sense but none of the common
kind what color is it
Brown no it's medium Sandalwood Jimmy
would be excellent at Crayola since it's
kind of busy here don't you think yeah
Witnesses are good you mean the
witnesses that can clearly see Saul
talking to the two kids right before all
this goes down she she hit and run
that's what I'm saying she failed and
wailed bailed and wailed really aside
from the fact that it should probably be
reversed and said wailed and bailed
that's your best skater rhyming slang
for a hit and run not crashed and dashed
slammed and scrammed zoomed and banged
and then boomeranged you're following
her how
our ways yo yeah except your way is
ridiculous you're telling me that you
snag the back of a vehicle headed her
Direction long after she sped off that
somehow conveniently caught her and
continued to follow her all the way home
look scared dudes even McFly had to
switch vehicles occasionally another
Breaking Bad Cameo except this one seems
completely out of left field one of the
chances this [ __ ] would be here in
this house right now oh well can't wait
to see all the adventures tuko gets into
on this show
looks like you picked the wrong Leisure
activity buddy make sure you click that
Bell icon but clicking the little bell
icon is how you make sure you get
notified every time we release a video
so click it sell out
they're the same size and model time
Friday I had a pretty cushy gig lots of
friends I was the office hottie now I'm
a severed head in the fridge I guess you
think you're uh you know like an
authority figure
that stupid [ __ ] uniform my buddy
can clip on side there big [ __ ] man
huh I'm a stickler yes you know it's a
stickler with the money yeah you see
we're putting the cover sheets on all
TPS reports now before they go out what
did you do what'd you do
good work and the clients the clients
will come give me a bill
he will come let me tell you
about a young guy Buttercup was raised
on a small farm